HIS CAREER AGAINST MONTREAL FOR
THE DUCKS ALL ABOUT NICELY.
IT'S A TURNOVER BY THE CANADIENS
CIRCLE SO HE STEPS IN AND WINSH.
SHATTENKIRK POPS INTO THE
.
GOOD PUCK MOVEMEMES PLAYED
23 MINUTES OR THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE AND NOW GETZLAF
GETS HOOKED AND ANOTHER PENALTY
COMING UP TO THE NOW.
SHATTENKIRK AND FOWLER. FINDS H.
SAVE, MONTEMBEAULT.
>> A REALNOIT BUT HE TURNS IT OR
HERE IN THE EARLY GOING, EVERY
TIME HE GETS THATT
I WAS GET
E FEELING IN A GAME LIKE THIS
THAT THEY GOT TO DON'T KNOW
IF IT WENT OUT OF PLAY OR NOT
BUT I THI THERE AS BENOIT GOT
TANGLED UP IN IT AND THEY
FINALLY AWAY.
DRYSDALE.
>> NO
KULAK
THERE IS THELED BY
THE CANADIENS.
CHIAROT ALL THE WAY TO THE
CORNER.
FIRES AT OFF THE STICK OF
GIGI
HE WASN'T BUYING.
SO HERE IS LUNDESTROM WITH A
HEAD OF NET.
HERE'S ANOTHER LOOK AT THE SAME
E
CREASE LIKE ROBBED.
AND ONLY ONE EVEN STRENGTH GOALS
SCORED AND WHAT IS A 2-2 TEAMMA.
>> IT'S A STRETCHT OFF THE TOP
OF THE FOOT.
PETRY HAMMERS